[Music]
we gotta walk like the cops do it heal
the toe show us i'm gonna start it off
okay go ahead
arrested
[Music]
okay jubilee
no chaser
no oh god why don't we start by just
doing quick introductions this is
kennedy she is from los angeles and she
is 25. this is bryce he's from new
jersey and he's also 25.
i'm roman and i'm 20 through
23 and
i'm from glendale i'm grace i'm 22 and
i'm from baltimore maryland
i'm okie i'm 41
and from the bay area my name is gabe
i'm 22 and i'm from massachusetts i'm
kat i'm 24.
i'm allergic to old lolly berries i want
people to know where i live
you don't want me you don't need to give
me a dress
what's the zip code what do you guys
think you're going to be looking for
speech for sure speech i guess i was
looking at people's like skin tone
whether they were getting flushed or not
if they were maybe being more boisterous
like loud can you walk straight can you
talk well
grace would you like to demonstrate can
you say the alphabet backwards we gotta
walk like the cops do it heal the toe
show us i'm gonna start it off okay go
ahead
wow
okay wait is that runway arrested
i'm doing it
[Applause]
i've trained my whole life for this yeah
[Music]
well am i supposed to like do this all
right let's go let's get them out let's
get in the pot
all right roman
i i can't tell
that thought he'll tell him
flawless well i'm gonna just say those
two already need to be over here you
think kennedy has to be over there
you're not the most drunk because you're
the most confident that's not how that
works the price is the control when you
put him in the middle and we'll adjust
from there it'll make it easier okay i
appreciate that okay
he's not that drunk he's not that
different right in the middle so let's
work down the line it's working like how
are you feeling how are you feeling i
think i'm pretty good how was this
compared to like a night out number two
this would be like i'm not even there so
you're at the pregame
yeah bryce are you more or less drunk
than cat
that's a tough question no that is
because you think you're more no he's
more i feel like we should start lining
top to bottom first let's meet let's get
both in who's the most wrong we need to
figure out a way to assess this let's
put our minds in the okay
okay okay guys okay guys i'm gonna start
self-assessing i think you should go up
this way okay i'm gonna go with you i'm
gonna go with you we're gonna go this
way i think you should go in the middle
he's not the least drunk he's not police
trump i think oaky is the least drunk
just go to
yes i feel like you're you deserve a
higher spot you gotta be in the least
second there's literally no way no no no
second or third and most i think you'd
be in the middle to be completely roman
[Applause]
i don't i feel like i would
i'm insulted i think i should be
maybe like
i fully agree with you well okay hold up
i have the i have the answers i have the
answer go on so how often do you drink
never okay he never drinks how often do
you drink five times a week my
girlfriend's a bartender okay
see see two times a week probably drinks
two times a week how often do you drink
like once a week yeah once a week
yeah
every day every day every day okay four
to five times a week okay i drink maybe
once
but i think i think that checks out as
to where you are right now bac is bac
based on like your height and weight
it's based on your your weight and your
gender it's on my refrigerator so i
don't know how many drinks i can have
there's no way this guy's more sober
than i am yeah not a chance
i love you but no i'm sorry i love you
too but you're incorrect i love you too
but i just met you
switch and i feel like we'll be yeah you
guys switch you'll are misunderstanding
i am not armenian i i mean
this is
so it only makes sense for me to mess up
it's not because i'm so sweet
i'm not the least drunk but i know i'm
less than you for at least a group
decision you'll be proven right if
you're right you'll be proven right they
said the time is up we need to figure
this out
that was it there's absolutely no way
no way no way bite me
you all ready yeah let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
point one one i told you i mean i knew
that he was hi
wait he should be dead that's not how
that works okay here we go
second i told you do we move
it's
almost exactly the same
0.117
it's going to be so low
i don't know which one of you guys works
on editing but you all can have a field
day with this one
what was yours
0.12 god damn it i mean gosh darn it
[Applause]
okay here we go
point one one two
this is what everybody's been waiting
for i just want to say i bet you guys
did i get it yeah we're waiting now
i bit
one point
one point one four nine
one four nine so prices we don't get
we got the same exact amount yeah
[Applause]
what can i say i mean
i'm honestly confused i took five shots
of tequila before this within an hour so
good for me i guess this man took 10.
yeah
it goes without saying bryce is not uh
an experienced alcohol consumer oh i
always knew bryce was the drunkest he
like had that no inhibition sort of
thing
thoughts
i did not think i was the most wrong
but they're inside i was and that's okay
[Music]
you